uh right now though we want to send it
over to nate tannenbaum with a very
special performance good morning nate
well thank you so much alex you know
today being christmas eve we have a
special flutie 2d holiday friday on a
thursday plus we don't have a show
tomorrow morning
i'm actually doing two songs today one
right now and a different one next hour
this is a classic that
i hope you recognized
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
booty
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much hope you're enjoying
your christmas eve at home
whatever your preparations are at the
last minute whatever your
frantic last minute shopping trip has to
be whether it's just to the drugstore to
get some more wrapping paper or you ran
out of tape
or you have to go ahead and get some
last minute gifts we'll be doing one
more christmas song for you in the next
hour
so much fun trying to spread some
christmas cheer
during what's been a difficult year for
all of us john sherry alex
thank you nate that was awesome
it was beautiful